in june 2021 the office of the director
of national intelligence issued its
long-awaited report on unidentified
aerial phenomena pollsters have been
asking americans about ufos since the
early 1970s and the public has long been
skeptical about what the government
knows about them a quarter century ago
71 percent told gallup the government
knew more than it was telling us this
summer before the government's report
came out 65 percent echoed that
sentiment in an economist yougov poll
eleven percent said the government had
told the public everything it knows and
24 weren't sure
the government found no evidence that
the aerial phenomena seen in recent
years were alien spacecraft but they
couldn't explain what is going on up in
the atmosphere
in a gallup question asked after the
report came out 41 said that they
believe some ufos have been
extraterrestrial spacecraft while 50
said all sightings could be explained by
human activity or natural phenomenon
it's clear that the government's report
hasn't dampened public interest in ufos
have you ever seen a ufo
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from aei